J'ai plus peur de mourir,
c'était déjà une expérience tout à fait unique
pour nous tous. Je pense que le fait de
recréer l'histoire de cet homme de
nous immerger dans le monde naturel pour essayer de
recréer sa lutte, le simple fait de le
faire dans ces endroits a donné
nous beaucoup de réponses sur ce que le
film était sur la chose sûre à faire est de
suivre un nouveau parcours en ligne, puis
ce que nous allons faire assis là comme un
tas de [ __ ] de canards vous et votre
fils libre de copain faites une promenade  à la sortie, je vous parle,
je voulais vraiment faire partie de
quelque chose d'incroyablement unique et dès le
premier plan qui a pris des semaines et des semaines
juste pour répéter et encore moins tirer et
tourner, nous savions que nous devions
continuer avec le niveau de  la réalisation de films qui
allait être incroyablement difficile,
nous savions dans une certaine mesure avant le
tournage du film que cela
allait être très difficile que cela allait
nous défier tous, mais il y a
quelque chose de très gratifiant à travailler au-delà
du poi  nt auquel il pensait que vous
ne pouviez plus en supporter
si nous pouvons ressentir à nouveau cette interaction
avec le froid et que les gens peuvent ressentir
la peur et mourir et la colère puis
renaître puis être guéris puis mourir à
nouveau si c'est le chef à travers  un
voyage émotionnel puis une mission
accomplie
par rapport à Jim ponts avec du verre Je l'ai en
quelque sorte toujours vu comme une sorte de
relation père-fils non officielle Je
pense que le joyau au moins Hugh glass était
la chose la plus proche qu'il avait d'un père qu'il
avait beaucoup  d'admiration pour le verre et
j'ai beaucoup appris en travaillant donc nous en avons fini avec lui et c'est vraiment comme ça que j'ai vu leur dynamique se jouer
qui a alimenté le genre d'agitation
qu'il ressent quand il est en quelque sorte obligé de l'
abandonner la bonne chose  pour
savoir que terminer rapidement, il pourrait être
soigné aussi longtemps que nécessaire Je
comprends ce qui était intéressant et donc
tout à fait utile pour nous tout en faisant
ce film était juste de comprendre leur
compréhension de l'histoire pendant que nous
faisions  ce film et en réfléchissant
à tout ce qui a été enlevé à leurs
cultures et nous considérons cette histoire comme
barbare, mais si vous regardez le reste
du monde de nos jours, cela se produit partout
dans le monde à un niveau sans précédent,
cette histoire n'est pas différente de  quand
les Espagnols sont arrivés en Amérique et dans mon
pays, vous savez, je pense qu'il est difficile de
juger ces gens sans le contexte
de cette époque car à cette époque,
évidemment, ils ne savaient pas beaucoup de
choses que nous savons maintenant ce qui est
frappant pour moi, c'est que  beaucoup de
choses qui étaient difficiles là-bas, c'est à quel
point cela n'a pas changé